in the opening scene we are introduced
to a martial arts expert and assassin
named thunderlag for his entire life
thunderleg has trained to be the best
fighter in the world he is known for his
signature technique called devil's kick
a swift and deadly kicking style that
can defeat even the best opponents one
day he receives a letter from a client
who wants him to kill a prominent kung
fu master named wei he has also paid a
hefty sum of money for his services not
wasting much time thunder goes to weigh
and challenges him to a fight way offers
him double the amount of money for his
life but thunder refuses even though he
is a fugitive he is a man of high
principles when it comes to his work the
fight starts and a master-like way is
proven weak in front of thunder he shows
amazing footwork and defeats the
opponent in a matter of minutes in the
following scene we are taken to the best
martial arts training center in the town
it is run by a master named wang and his
disciple professor
kai the trainees are scared of wang but
none of them fear kai the most notorious
one of all the trainees is wang's own
son freddy he teases kai and laughs at
the others at his misery when kai
realizes what is going on he calls out
freddie for being a spoiled brat and
taking advantage of his father's
position and having a white ass name
they decide to settle the conflict with
a fight kai loses because even though he
is a professor he is not half as good as
freddie the man has a natural talent in
martial arts and is only lacking proper
discipline later that day freddy is with
his friends in the market planning to
prank people as they usually do he uses
an eel to scare a girl and make her jump
on him however he is caught by the
girl's mother she is also a master in
kung fu and is better than any opponents
freddie has faced he has taught a lesson
before he registers he cannot win
against her and flees luck is not in
freddy's favor that day because on the
way back home he sees a guy named jerry
he is troubling a poor seller by
refusing to pay the right amount freddy
stands against the bully and defeats him
in a fight to make him pay the seller
and because he has an even wider ass
name than freddy before leaving he warns
jerry to stay out of his sight if he
values his life in the evening he
returns home and sees that the girl he
pranked earlier and her mother are with
his father freddy tries his best to
ignore them but his father calls him
closer to introduce him to the guests it
turns out they are his aunt and cousin
who have come to visit them from a
different city they tell master wong
about his son's shenanigans getting
freddie in trouble just when he is about
to be punished they are interrupted by a
landowner named lee he is jerry's father
and is furious at freddy for beating up
his son jerry is also brought in front
of master huang covered in bandages from
all the injuries inflicted upon him lee
doesn't want an apology but wants
freddie to be punished for his crimes
wang brings out a stick to hit freddy
but is stopped by his aunt she asks the
victim's friends to punish freddie in a
way that they prefer but they only get
10 hits on him and he cannot fight back
in between the hits one of jerry's
friends confidently comes forward but
fails to recognize that even if freddie
cannot counter-attack he can defend
himself his first few hits go to waste
because freddie is able to deflect each
one of them eventually the 10 attacks
are over and freddy is still standing
upright with no major injuries when the
opponent tries going for an extra attack
freddy sends him flying with a single
hit lee and his goons have to pick jerry
up and return home in embarrassment but
master wong's anger hasn't died down yet
starting the next day he makes freddy go
through a series of brutal punishments
he is made to squat with bowls on his
head and shoulders for hours every day
still freddie and his friends find
several ways to cheat their way out of
the punishment master wong finds out
about this and is fed up with his son's
lack of discipline deciding to take a
major step he calls his brother a
legendary kung fu master named sam he is
best known for the drunken style of kung
fu and is unbeatable when drunk long
believes that under his care even
someone like freddy will start taking
life seriously until he arrives freddy
is kept in the outhouse with a heavy pot
hung on his neck as punishment his
friend rescues him and reveals that
master sam is not a usual person he
tortures his students so much that they
are unrecognizable by the end of the
training once he arrives freddy might as
well wish farewell to his freedom and
peace upon hearing all of the gruesome
things that sam has done freddy no
longer wants to meet him he runs away
and ends up at a restaurant by the end
of the day since he is penniless he
tricks a man into treating him to a meal
but the man turns out to be the
restaurant's owner his goons start a
fight with freddy for trying to cheat
them in the same restaurant master sam
is enjoying a meal he recognizes freddy
and helps him fight the goons freddy is
thankful to the stranger for his help as
they talk he starts insulting master sam
failing to recognize that he is the same
man after berating him all he wants
freddy stops and asks the stranger his
name upon finding out that he has the
whitest name of them all and is the
master freddy's face changes color he
tries to make a run for it when that
doesn't work he foolishly attempts to
fight sam and is taught a quick lesson
starting the next day his training
begins and his first task is to
repeatedly transfer water from one
massive pot to another he looks for the
right moment and pretends to have fallen
into one of the pots when sam comes to
his aid he is tricked and trapped inside
freddy then runs away and comes to rest
at an abandoned building the place turns
out to be the hideout of the dangerous
assassin thunderlag he orders freddy to
go away but unaware of the killer's
identity freddy refuses as a result
thunderleg proceeds to beat up and
humiliate him he is about to kill him
but stops because killing a mere
weakling like freddy would harm his
reputation freddie's life is saved but
he hasn't been more embarrassed in his
entire life the anger turns into the
will to get revenge on thunder and for
that he has to train in the following
scene he goes back to sam apologizing
and begging him for his help sam takes
him back giving him the last chance to
prove himself the first step in training
is to multiply his arm strength this is
done by sam tying sticks to his hands
and using him like a puppet after
training the entire day freddy has a
hard time using chopsticks at dinner he
doubts if he can ever be as strong as
thunder but as the days pass he feels
his arms gaining strength the first
quarter of the training ends when he can
break walnuts with his bare fingers then
one day the master and student go to a
local betting zone to gamble sam is an
experienced gambler with very sharp eyes
he wins every single round and makes a
lot of money much to the annoyance of
his opponents they are interrupted by a
bald man who thinks he can defeat sam
they put all their money on the last
round but the man cheats to win upon
being proven a fraud he panics and
starts blaming sam freddy challenges him
to a fight thinking it will be an easy
win but the bald man reveals he has been
trained in skull style kung fu and has a
powerful head he overpowers freddy in
the first half of the fight but freddie
gets his hands on a hammer and defeats
the guy in the end a while later master
sam runs out of his favorite alcohol and
asks freddie to get him some from a
restaurant however he instead eats a
large meal with the money and dilutes
the alcohol with water assuming that sam
won't know the difference somewhere else
the bald-headed guy brings the bamboo
master to beat up sam for what he did
earlier the bamboo master has his stick
but sam lacks his biggest source of
power which is alcohol freddy arrives at
the right time but sam instantly
recognizes that the alcohol is deluded
as a result both of them cannot fight
the bamboo master so they decide to flee
at night freddy blamed sam for not
teaching him properly because he
couldn't defeat the bamboo master sam
reveals that until now he had only been
learning the basics of the drunken kung
fu technique now that he has mastered
the basics he will have to learn the
more important parts the duo then drinks
until they are drunk out of their minds
when an average person can hardly walk
with this much alcohol in their system
sam can perform the techniques of all
seven masters of kung fu freddy learns
about the masters and their strengths
and weaknesses after training for hours
and hours he finally begins to get a
hang of the complicated techniques of
kung fu he is also much more disciplined
than he was before and takes the
training more seriously one day the
landowner li comes to master wang asking
him to sell his land wang knows that lee
wants to misuse the land by converting
it into a coal mine lee even offers him
20 percent of the profit but wang kicks
him out in the following scene thunder
leg receives a letter from a client the
sender is lee who wants him to murder
wong thunder takes on the task and gets
ready to go to the city somewhere else
freddie is walking home with alcohol
when he comes across the bamboo master
he remembers how he and sam were
humiliated by the man and decides to
take revenge he provokes the man urging
him to make the first attack the fight
seems to be neutral until freddy drinks
alcohol when he is drunk no one can
fight against him not even the popular
bamboo master he defeats the man almost
hilariously before stealing two large
pots of his wine however on reaching
home he is shocked to see sam is missing
he finds a letter where the master has
thanked him for believing in his
teachings he says freddie has learned
everything there is to know about
drunken kung fu hence he has completed
his task and is leaving back in the
training center a man runs to wang in a
panic and reveals that lee and his
people are taking over the land by force
an enraged wong goes to teach them a
lesson but finds no one it is revealed
that the notice was a trick played by
thunderleg to get wong alone thunder is
especially excited about the battle
because he is always looking for a
stronger opponent he thinks wong is a
perfect match for him and his death will
elevate thunder's reputation the fight
begins and the two match in strength and
technique for some time but when thunder
decides to use the devil's kick even the
mighty wong is defeated he is thrown to
the ground and is seconds away from
being killed when one of his disciples
brings freddie his blood boils on seeing
his father injured he gets ready to
fight the opponent in wong's place
thunderleg remembers him from the time
he was humiliated to the assassin it is
a joke because he thinks freddie is the
same person who ran away with his tail
between his legs the first time just
then sam arrives at the battlefield much
to freddie's delight thunder like
freezes in shock knowing what the
drunken master is capable of it turns
out he is the only person the deadly
assassin is scared of but sam assures
him that he will not interfere in the
fight he wants it to be between his
student and thunder the fight starts and
freddy dodges all of thunder's attacks
the opponent gets frustrated and makes a
mistake giving freddy an upper hand in
the end he uses his arm strength to snap
thunder's neck and defeats him lastly
freddy stands as the victor and his
father is finally proud of him subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching